he's on the right hand of the one that's
on high so he's on high with him right
no he's not that on high come on dog
does Christ sit on high in the throne
not the Lord's throne but he's he's the
highest before the I I don't want to use
that word
highest it's the F yeah that you would
love for me to say
that the son's Throne he when he rules
that's when he has the throne he's
waiting is he ruling right is he ruling
right now no he's not ruling what
it's
God it's
God the captain himself in the building
sir hey what's up man peace to the panel
peace to JP got logic two questions in
that conversation that last conversation
you was having with the brother when he
showed you that a man was worshiped why
did you go to prostrate instead of
excuse me homage instead of worship
that's to you JP and to the other
gentlemen yeah because again we see in
the Bible that worship can happen to
somebody but it's not the same as God so
what word and I did is that he showed an
example in the Book of Revelation where
the Father and Jesus received the same
exact worship because the worship David
got not the worship that they give to
Yahweh but in that verse it's not given
a separate worship for the most high and
the King it's given the same worship for
the most high and the king so are you
saying they just paid homage to the most
high was we can logically deduct that if
it was the same worship and David
received the same worship he would have
eventually gotten rebuked because the
Bible is clear that that worship only
belongs to God God doesn't share his
glory with anybody can we agree with
that does God share his glory god
doesn't God definitely shares his glory
with whom he sees you can see in John
you see the 17- 21 off the top of my
head when Christ not only asks for Glory
but also ask the children of Israel to
be partakers of the same Glory so he
definitely gives his glory in Isaiah 42
and it says I would not give my glory to
another that's specifically like if we
all on this panel no matter our beliefs
we all believe in the most high no
matter how you get there we all believe
in the most high the difference is if is
one of us tried to bring Egyptian gods
to that if one of us tried to bring
Babylonian now that's giving his glory
to another but to say that he don't give
his glory but I what I don't want to get
past is in 1 Chronicles 29 and 20 when
you say we can deduce that's you putting
your indoctrination on it because that's
just one word they Worship the Lord and
the king and then when the brother it
wasn't yes so no creature receives the
same worship that God receives so if
they worshiped the king in any capacity
it wasn't in the same way as God no
creature is worshiped like God can you
agree that no creature is worshiped like
God do you I don't think I don't think I
don't think no person including Christ
is worshiped like God but even is a is a
lamb a creature is a lamb a creature yes
the the lamb is not a creature the lamb
lamb is it the lion the lion of Judah
the F first the fact that he's being
called a lamb let me address your
question Captain real quick what God has
called a man so yeah well I was gonna
say the lion the lamb those are not an
eag too a shield called a shield and
Rock come on man y yall done so now in
Revelations in Revelations 5 it clearly
says worship God and the lamb in
Revelations 5 so the same way when you
ask that question the same way it gave a
difference in Revelations is the same
way is given a difference in 1
Chronicles it's more distinctive yall
going to interrupt me again it's more
distinctive in Revelations 5
because in Revelations 5 you clearly see
God on the throne as the brother said
that brother cut y' bad as that brother
said you see the God on the throne the
seven spirit let me I'm looking at it in
the parallel give me one second so you
look at that verse and matter of fact we
start at verse four mean chapter four
rather that's when you see the father on
the throne and everybody screaming his
name holy holy holy Lord God Almighty
which was which is and was to come
that's the father that's who's on the
throne
then in Revelations 5 the lamb is
presented Before the Throne so if God is
on the throne the lamb is being
presented Before the Throne the same way
in Revelations 5 when it says um
blessing honor glory and power be unto
him read in verse 13 be unto him that
sth upon the throne the one that sth
upon the throne brother brother brother
um I can't let you go on a soliloquy
we're only here for 30 more minutes so
let me respond I'm just reading the
scripture you just interrupted the
scripture that's all you did yeah
brother but let me respond to you
because you've gone for a long time the
AR yes you brother I'm sitting here
listening to you now it's our turn to
respond let us respond it's not a
problem you can go on you took a shot
you said he cut us no he did not you
know let's go through the scripture
right I'm not gonna go you yeah he did
no he didn't let's stick to the
scripture the scripture is clear that
the lamb and God are there and they
receive the worship from every Every
Creature from Every Creature if Jesus
just was solely a creature he would have
been one of the creatures to be
worshiping God but he was not one of the
creatures worshiping God he was being
worshiped alongside God that with the
same exact worship now you said earlier
that no human receives the same worship
as God in this particular example there
receiving the same worship it doesn't
make a distinction they're receiving the
same worship so then I ask you the same
question when you brought up quranic and
you said David was being worshiped are
you saying that there is a human that is
worshiped just how God is
worshiped I answered that question I
said first of all even Christ is not
receiving the same worship as God in
Revelations because in Revelations 4
there is nobody standing in front of
Christ saying holy holy holy Lord God
Almighty which was which is and is to
come that only applies to the father
that only applies to the most high so
the same it's different you're interrup
now you're interrupting me now what you
doing here what we doing okay so go
ahead preach a sermon Captain tesar take
over the I mean it's always easy to say
preach a sermon when you're getting cut
when you get cut you say preach a sermon
when when you comfortable you just sit
back and just wait for them to finish
and walk into the body bag because even
this is not a moderated debate you
interrupted me though when I was
responding to you preach a sermon
brother even in the verbage that you
gave as you say preach sermon even in
the verbage that you came say did every
time you spoke you said God and then you
said Jesus you cut yourself even in your
response because clearly you're
acknowledging God is on the throne and
then you're saying Christ is being
worshiped with the same as God even in
your response you cut yourself so again
Christ is not receiving the same worship
even in heaven because he's not getting
pleaded to Holy Holy Holy so 1
Chronicles 29 they worshiping the Lord
and the king that's what it says in
Revelations 5 and9 they bowing down and
giving blessing honor glory and power
unto him that sit on the throne now can
I ask a question well let me respond to
what you said I raised my hand I wasn't
I wasn't looking to see if he raise your
hand y'all the only ones with the adim
because it hurt no no no no no I'm not
making Adam I'm raising my hand I want I
don't want well I gu saying you got cut
by the previous callers technically Adam
I'll give you that reason that I said
Jesus and I said God I made a
distinction so just for the sake of
conversation there's a distinction so
when I talk about Jesus and I say the
father and I say Jesus that's not
because I am saying Jesus is not God so
that is a straw man I think I have to
correct that when I say the lamb the
lamb is God the lamb is being worshiped
the same way the father's being
worshiped what you do is you mention a
couple of angels that are worshiping the
father in a particular way and then
you're saying that that means that Jesus
is not God because the father is being
worshiped in a particular way by the way
the father calls what
happened no when you don't I want to ask
something yes yes well let me just
finish this the father himself calls
calls Jesus God but wait just because
because I call the father father and
Jesus Jesus it doesn't mean Jesus isn't
God so I just wanted to correct that go
ahead Nick and then Captain had a
question all right so in uh in Isaiah 6
6 and3 when it says holy holy holy is
the Lord of hosts the whole earth is
full of his glory who who is that a
reference to I would have to go to it
and see no I got it right now yeah so
start off in verse one Isaiah 6 and
one
wow in the year that King Uzziah died I
saw the Lord sitting upon his throne
sitting upon a throne high and lifted up
and the train of his robe filled the
temple above him stood the seraphim each
had six wings with two he covered his
face and with two he covered his feet
and with two he flew and one called to
another and said holy holy holy is the
Lord of hosts the whole earth is full of
his glory so who does uh who does John
tell us that Isaiah saw if you go to
John
1241 can we go to John 12:41 before I
answer yeah thank
you I'm
there okay so Isaiah said these things
because he saw his glory and spoke of
him who who's the he and the him that
John is referring to that's the most
high is
that yeah I agree it is the most high
but who game over open for JP I can see
when people be in their feelings so when
you read that these things you said I
got cut I'm giving you your same
medicine I'm just I'm not bothered you
know just because I gave a response back
I'm not yelling I a I ain't being rude I
just put calmly said who's y'all been in
your feelings since I came on the stage
so when you read that it's talking about
the report of the Lord these things
sayith isias right that's in John 12
when you go back to Isaiah 6 and when it
says and then I still want to be able to
ask my question when you go back to 6
and you just keep reading when it says
in verse 8 also I heard the voice of the
Lord saying who shall I send and who
will I go for us then said I here I am
send me so when they're seeing that
Vision up there I don't know why y'all
did this when they seeing that vision of
the Lord the Lord still sent someone so
when you keep reading down the Lord sent
someone and it says who will go for us
and he said here I send me that's Christ
who did I who did I so now can I ask my
question now that's
Isaiah I can't help I can't help but if
y'all slow who who did Isaiah who did
Isaiah see cap also I heard of the voice
of the Lord saying who shall I send and
who will go for us then said I here am I
send me so who did Isaiah see who did
Isaiah see and then who's the US that
he's who did Isaiah see cap the US I'm
going say it in reverse I already
answered and said said the most high saw
excuse me Isaiah saw the most high the
Holy Holy when it says one Cried unto
another holy holy I already said that's
the most high in verse eight you ask me
who is the US that's the most high
saying who will go for us the US would
be the counsel you can see the counsel
of the Lord in I think it's First Kings
could be 21 when the Lord had the host
on the left and host on the right what
did he do then he said who will go down
to convince Ahab and then the lion
spirit said I go excuse me a Spirit came
and said I'll be a Lon spirit in the
mouth of All His prophets it's called
counsel so now do I get to ask my
question just one follow-up question in
the passage you just referenced with the
lying Spirit did he say who will go for
us he didn't have to say who will go for
us because there was already a council
in that Council they're all speaking and
discussing the matter remember the
question sure no I I I agree so when
there's a council it's clear that
there's a council there so where's the
council here here when he asks the
question that's it's very simple
understanding if the voice of the Lord
says who shall go for us the Lord is
speaking for the us if the Lord says who
will convince Ahab to fall he's speaking
just like in 1 Chronicles 29 and 20 it
said just bow down to the Lord and the
King but in Revelations 5 and9 it gives
more detail but it's the same thing the
most high being worshiped King being
worshiped most high being worship
blessed and gloried and honored the lamb
being blessed gloried and honored so now
can I ask my question I'm clearly
answering all your question you're not
you're not dealing with it though yet
bro yeah I I dealt with it cleanly I
answer who the US is I answer who's on
the throne so if you're saying that
Isaiah saw Isaiah saw the most high who
does John say that Isaiah saw in John 12
John is
recalling this is so sad in John 12
John is recalling BAS John is recalling
in verse eight when the Lord says who
shall be sent one said I that's Christ
coming no that's okay so John is saying
that Isaiah saw Christ no John is
referencing so in John 12 and 40 he had
blinded their eyes and Harden their
heart that they should not see with
their eyes nor understand with their
heart and be converted and I should heal
them these things say thesias when he
saw his glory and spake of him that's
that that's it right there yeah these
things Isaiah say when he saw his glory
and spake of him then it says never so
so who so Isaiah saw the glory of the
most high right he saw the glory of the
most high when he's speaking of
him just let me know it yeah yeah we got
it just just short quick quick you know
answer question well it's two it's two
it's two parts when it says he saw his
glory and spake of him the spake of him
is him speaking of Christ the glory is
what he saw of the most high to speak of
him is when the Lord
said it's the same person it's not the
same person I know y'all all want to
interrupt but I'm trying to answer one
question at a time so now when it says
he spake of him you cannot deny that the
Lord said who's going to go for us and
that the person that responded is Christ
that's the spake of him also all of that
y'all want to isolate that's that's the
problem with you Christians y'all want
to isolate the verse instead of getting
the full context isolate it what I
didn't isolate no no no I didn't isolate
anything I clearly y'all only read two
verses Isaiah 6 and3 John 12:41 I'm the
one that gave more context by reading
further down in both
chapters when do I when do I get to act
when do I get to ask my question because
y'all G say y g say yeah we got we gotta
deal with this completely say y y gonna
run okay you can say that no keep that
up JP keep it up so you're you're
arbitrarily separating the his and the
him as if these are two different like
there's nowhere in the context where the
his is not the him in the same freaking
sentence where it says Isaiah said these
things because he saw his glory and
spoke of him talk about the same person
which then you see in verse 42
nevertheless many even of the
authorities believed in him who who is
that the the most high it's talking
about Jesus clearly but for fear of the
Pharisees they did not confess it so
that they would not be uh put out of the
synagogue for they love the glory that
comes from man then the glory that comes
from God so you have that John here is
highlighting that Isaiah saw the glory
of Christ and spoke of Christ and the
Pharisees even some of them believed in
Christ but didn't announce it loudly
while at the same time referring back to
Isaiah where Isaiah saw the glory of the
most high so who does that make
Jesus are you done now yeah horrible
when when John 12:41 these things sayith
esias you're choosing to stop at verse
three I'm choosing to go to the context
of the conversation that's taking place
in Isaiah the 6th chapter and when you
keep reading when it says spake of him
the reason why it's speaking of Christ
because when the Lord spake or spoke so
now the glory is when he spoke in verse
Isaiah 6 and3 you I'm sorry the glory is
when you see the glory Isaiah 6 and3 but
when did he speak in verse 9 verse eight
and I heard the voice of the Lord saying
whom shall I send and who will go for us
so you're isolating once again because
you wanted to just be Jesus's God
because it says holy holy holy but you
have to acknowledge that the Lord spoke
as well and when it says it spake of him
the Lord spoke and it was Christ said
send me so the spake of him is the one
being sent that's Isaiah body bag that's
a body bag body B because in John can I
when do I get to ask my question man
right after y'all keep saying right
after and they keep coming back to it
cap let make a make it clear let me just
make it clear for you we're not gonna
move on until this is settled bro we're
not just gonna let you I'm settled y'all
just get getting cut that's why y'all
keep want to explain it you keep trying
to like go in a little Soliloquy and
preach and then y'all keep saying that I
I don't y keep saying that you can't do
that on man let me ask my question I'm
only asking my question after I respond
to y'all statement but I cut y'all and
y'all W to keep talking cap when you
when you're getting put in a hermeneutic
body bag like this this has to be
settled first then you can ask your next
question you're trying to shuffle so bad
bro I don't think you understand what I
mean no no I don't understand what you
mean I'm I'm G tell you what I mean I'm
confident that I beat y'all on this
point y'all are not confident y'all are
not confident that y'all beat me on this
point that's why y'all keep going back
and forth because if y'all was confident
you would say fine just like the last
brother that y'all got rid of just like
the last brother said we can move on
y'all was comfortable saying we can move
on because y'all felt conf confident
that y'all beat him y'all are not
confident right now because the point
was settled I think that is showing that
the fact that you're trying so hard to
run away from the the the issue here I'm
not
answer trying so bad to get off of
this away from this so let's
stop JP said y'all had a certain amount
of time I didn't want y'all to stay on
this subject and then you when I ask my
question you say well we running out of
time that's clearly when you go back and
listen that's what I said when I first
said that I said that when it first
started but if y'all want to keep going
back and forth on this B mean by all
means don't bother
me yeah I I would just like to hammer
this home real quick so we're not the
ones isolating the passage John isolated
that passage John
isolated that he saw him and spoke of
his glory what is the passage that he
quoted Isaiah 6 and3 we started at verse
one
and remember what it said it said I saw
the Lord he saw him how do you how do
you see the most
high how did is question question how
did is okay I know you was asking me a
question when we when we go to Isaiah
I'm just going to go to I'm just going
back to it because I have John on my
phone so I'm just going back to Isaiah 6
it says it's uh he said he lift up I I
excuse me I also saw the Lord sitting
upon the throne high and lifted up and
his train filled the temple above it the
six seraps each Had Each one had six
wings with with Twain he covered his
feet and with Twain he covered his feet
and with Twain he def fly and he cried
unto another say holy holy holy is the
Lord of ghosts excuse me host the whole
earth is here excuse me the whole earth
is full of his
glory you want me to keep reading no you
don't have to keep reading I'm saying so
it starts off he saw the Lord how how
does one see the Lord see well when he
looked up he saw he's seeing exactly
what it says I'm I'm not arguing that
okay so you believe the most high God
can be
seen I I believe you can see the glory
whatever Vision the Lord allows you to
see John saw the same vision did not
John record the same vision that we're
talking about here in Isaiah 6 did not
John record that in Revelations the 4th
chapter yeah
that's my point and that same
Revelations us that he saw he saw Jesus
no no that's once again now you're
imparting something because it says
because because all John says is the
these things sayith isias which we know
is Isaiah when he saw his glory and
spake of him here's the positions both
sides are taken y'all taking the
position this is about Jesus I'm taking
the position that it's not that's what
John took the position that was Jesus
trying to openend it so I could let you
know where we're coming from so you're
taking it from the position that Jes
that's Jesus I'm taking the position
that it's not all John says is these
things saith isias when he saw his glory
and spake of him you stop in that verse
three doesn't answer spake of him but I
understand your position you take the
position that Isaiah is the one when it
says spake of him the spake is Isaiah
that's the position you take correct
yeah Isaiah Isaiah spoke
isah right so when it says and spake of
him you'll taking that as that's what
Isaiah said so I'm letting you know I
understand your position so when y'all
say I'm not getting it I so you do y'all
agree that I get your position now so
you so you understand that Isaiah is
speaking of Jesus I'm just asking if you
understand that I get your position I
disagree but I can understand your
position I'm just making sure you want
because you said I'm not getting it so
the reason why I'm doing it this way is
so you can see that I get your position
okay so we agree right you agree that I
understand your position right the
reason why I dis thank you so the reason
why I disagree with the position that
you take is because when it says these
say these things sayith isias when he
saw his glory and spake of him when I
when I go to Isaiah the 6th chapter I
have to read to where he spoke of him in
verse three he's not speaking of him
because it continues and when you get to
verse 8 when he says I heard the voice
of the Lord saying who shall I send and
who shall go for us even when I really
use this part but even when you look at
John 12 and 41 it doesn't highlight just
first John 6 it highlights 1 John 6 1-5
and then 8-10 so it doesn't even just do
that so for me in my position when it
says who shall go for us the US is the
Lord taking counsil Christ answering and
then Christ fulfilling it in John the
12th chapter okay so
Isaiah so Isaiah didn't see Christ high
and lifted up is that's what you're
saying cap that's what he's trying to
say he didn't see Christ high and lifted
up okay so in Isaiah same is the
same how did you let GIC answer GIC is
not
tar G logic is not
tar you just let you just let GIC relax
bro come on goodness when you say when
you saying relax all I said was godic is
not that's why that's why I had ask you
but but when God logic answered but when
God logic answered for me you accepted
it as my answer say anything you cut him
off while he was talking you went right
to Isaiah 5 Fus what is all this like
this what is this I mean what I don't
know why yall try to push the narrative
I've not been rude or interrupted you
the brother as me let's chill talk about
the scripture
let's quit let's quit debating about the
interruption and let's get don't answer
for me okay I apologize for answering
for you is that okay can we move on good
Lord in the year it seem like I'm doing
something wrong here are you all right
I'm just fine okay so can we talk about
the
scripture okay in Isaiah 61 in the year
that King Uzziah died I saw the Lord
sitting upon the throne who is who's
speaking
Isaiah all right who did he see the most
high who is he speaking of the most high
so here we see him seeing someone's
glory and speaking of that per same
person that he saw
right yes so there's not a
differentiation if I be quiet it's an
agree it's an agreeance just so you know
because I don't know if you always
asking me a question okay so we see that
there's not a distinction between Isaiah
uh seeing the person and speaking of
that same person he saw he saw him and
he spoke of him and he's telling us what
He Saw and he's speaking of his glory
and speaking of his his magnificence can
we
agree yeah he's speaking of I agree
silence isent silence isent all right
cool all
right so Isaiah saw the Lord and he
spoke of the Lord just like when we see
John says that he saw his glory and
spoke of him now let's just get down to
the part that you're you know that
you're talking about where you don't
think it's Isaiah anymore you think it's
Jesus um there's just we're just going
to continue to read in context above him
stood the seraphim each had six wings so
on and so forth holy holy holy Lord of
hosts you know so on and so forth and
the foundations of the threshold Shook
at the voice of him who called and the
house was filled with smoke and I said
woe is me for I am lost for I am a man
of unclean lips and I dwell in the midst
of people of unclean lips for my eyes
have seen the
king the Lord of hosts we agree this is
Isaiah still talking now
right all right yes verse six then one
of the seraphim flew to me having in his
hand a burning coal that he had taken
with tongs from The Altar and he touched
my mouth and said behold this has
touched your lips your guilt is taken
away and your sin is atoned
for and verse eight and I heard the
voice of the Lord saying this is Isaiah
saying what he heard
right all right Isaiah speaking saying
he heard the voice of the Lord so now
the Lord is about to say whom shall I
send and whom will go for us then I said
is this Isaiah speaking
still yes all right so Isaiah says here
I am send me and he said go and say to
this people so the person being sent to
the people which is Israel is Isaiah
this isn't Jesus he's speaking to Jes
Jesus is the one commanding him telling
him to go to the people of Israel
Isaiah's the one being sent so therefore
when you're because we understand what
you're saying too you're saying that
right here God speaks to the like is is
referring to the Divine counsel and
Jesus Christ steps up and says here I am
send me and it's not Isaiah that's Jesus
however we just agreed that it was
Isaiah that said here I am send me and
then the Lord sent him so the one who
Isaiah is speaking of and who he saw the
glory of is still the most high who John
says is
Jesus get the whole point so now the way
you did Isaiah do John so in John 12 it
says 36 before we get to 41 it says
while you have light believe in the
light that you may be the children of
the light these things spake Jesus and
departed and did hide himself from them
we agree that that's Jesus talking but
though he had done so many miracles
before them yet they believed not on him
then saying then excuse me that the
saying of Isaiah's the prophet might be
fulfilled which he spake Lord who hath
believed thy report and to whom the arm
of the Lord have been revealed this is
said in the book of Isaiah right yeah we
agree so when Isaiah is saying that is
the armor of the Lord
revealed and Isaiah Isaiah is saying
this yes but has the armor of the Lord
been revealed yet when Isaiah says that
no but the armor of the Lord is revealed
when Christ comes right
correct verse 39 therefore they could
not believe because that Isaiah said
again he had blinded their eyes and
Harden their hearts that they should not
see with their eyes nor understand with
their heart and be converted and I
should heal them did Christ do the exact
same thing do what exactly the blinded
their eyes and Harden their hearts that
they should not see with their eyes nor
understand with their heart and be
converted sure Christ did the same thing
so now we see as we read in the upper
verses the arm of the Lord was not
revealed yet even though Isaiah is
saying it that the blind eyes are Harden
Christ did that so when it in 41 when it
says these things said isias when he saw
his glory and spake of him that's not
talking about Christ being God I'm I'm
sorry I'm going read verse 42 before I
respond verse 42 nevertheless among the
chief rulers also me he believed on him
but because of the Pharisees they did
not confess him so when it says these
things sayth isias when he saw his glory
and spake of him it's recapping all the
things that that Isaiah had in
conversations about the most high about
Christ that hadn't necessarily happened
yet and it says when he saw his glory
now it's giving you the ear Mark of when
it occurred but it is not saying that
Jesus is God it's not saying that that's
you imparting Dogma onto it it's not
saying that may I interject here because
yes it wouldn't I'm not I don't to
interject anything if Isaiah here is I'm
sorry if John identifies that Jesus is
the one that Isaiah is speaking about so
Jesus according to Isaiah's words Jesus
is the arm of the Lord
correct Jesus is the arm he's not the
Lord okay no no worries so Jesus is the
arm of the Lord who Isaiah spoke about
now continuing on therefore they could
not believe for again Isaiah said so now
referring to something else that Isaiah
said which we saw in chapter six that he
has blinded their their eyes and Harden
their hearts as they see with their eyes
and understand y y y right Isaiah said
these things now this it's talking about
the Lord who did this right according to
Isaiah right what in 40 in verse in
chapter six who's the one who blinded
their eyes and Harden their hearts
according to wait let me go back there
hold let me go back there Isaiah 6 and
what verse
um uh is this in Isaiah I don't think
this is Isaiah 6 it might be in a
different wait I'm
sorry it's verse 10 it says
yeah it's actually verse nine and 10
yeah so he says um so so go and say to
this people right keep on hearing but do
not understand keep un seeing but do not
perceive make the heart of this people
Dole and their ears heavy and blind
their eyes lest they see with their eyes
and hear with their ears and understand
with their hearts and turn and be healed
right so who's doing that's that that's
Isaiah that Christ is doing too that's
what
Christ when he says go and tell this
people that's Isaiah doing that that
Christ is doing the exact same thing
that's what I just said when it says he
had blinded their eyes my question to
you was did Isaiah do this and Christ do
this and you agree with me
yeah so but so according to this Isaiah
is the one being sent to go do this
right okay so Isaiah's been being sent
to go do this at the command of the Lord
who he's telling us about and who he saw
correct on the throne yes yes okay this
is He Saw His glory he saw the glory
okay corre so he saw his glory and is
speaking of the one who he saw which
John says that that is Jesus no that's
once again the glory has nothing to do
with Jesus at all meaning the glory when
it's talking about seeing him on the
throne how we know this let's say if
Revelations did not exist you might have
a better argument but because
Revelations exist we see Isaiah 6 talk
about the most high the father sitting
on the throne we see Revelations saying
the father is sitting on the throne that
saying the exact same things Christ is
not on the father's Throne is no he's
not he really
said it goes right into my question
which if y'all let me ask the question
um it they kind of now that we got to
this part my question ties into what
we're talking about because you're
saying Christ sits on the father's
Throne the according to revelation 22
whose Throne is it in Revelations 221 I
don't know what verse you're talking
about but you going to another question
can I ask my question which is I'm
telling you my question is in line logic
my question is right in line with Throne
so even when you yeah I got you but you
just asked me about does Jesus sit on
the throne of the father I only said
that because you said it you said Jesus
sits on the same Throne of his father
and I just retorted by repeating the
same thing that you said first okay so
here's look here's here's here's the
answer Revelation 221 then the angel
showed me the river of the Water of Life
bright as Crystal flowing from the
throne singular the Throne of God and
the
lamb singular Throne belonging to both
God and the lamb so that makes you
believe that Christ sits on the same
Throne right they have they they have
the same so can I ask my question now or
at least the same Authority and power
say that can I ask my question now and
Luke 1 and
32 I believe it is Luke chapter 1
verse yeah 32 it says he shall be called
great and she he shall be called son of
the highest and the Lord God shall give
unto him the Throne of his father David
this why I said the same question was on
Throne so David's Throne is not God's
Throne right in a literal
sense in a literal sense no but but the
scri so just just for the record when
I'm right just for the record when I'm
saying Christ doesn't sit in his
father's Throne I'm talking in a literal
sense as well I'm not talking about like
in Revelations the thir chapter when it
says to him that overcome will I give
power to sit with me in my Throne as I
sit with my father in his throne that's
not the same seat that's just talking
about in Authority or headship or order
but in this verse here number one Christ
has two fathers in this verse we agree
right uh D David is ancestor and God the
Father sure so we he has two fathers
right yeah and we see that the day David
Throne is the throne that Christ is
going to actually sit on correct sure so
in Revelations 5 because we know that
that's not David's Throne that's how you
know in Isaiah 6 that same Throne which
is also not David is not Christ sitting
on said Throne AO he's not God all right
so let's let's let's let's go ahead and
give her autal here so I got a live
stream as well I appreciate you going
past the time live I knew you would I
knew got I knew you would I knew you
would so so um according to Isaiah 6
who's the one that's uh this Throne that
he sees that the Lord is sitting on in
his glory where where is this where is
this Throne I would say like it's in the
fourth dimension it's in the the Lord
okay in the in the heavens or something
like that on high okay do Christ sit on
high in the
throne not the Lord's throne but he's
he's the highest before the I I don't
want to use that word highest but his
throne I would say the F like if I was
to go hierar it's the yeah that you
would love for me to say
that the head of every man is Christ the
head of Christ is God so I wouldn't put
I wouldn't say Christ has a highest
Throne because that would disrespect the
most high no wor you said does he have
you said does he have thrown on high
yeah where yeah where is his thrown on
high you would have to show me if you
got a verse or something to
explain I so you don't you don't
know you would have to show me okay so
in Hebrews chapter one verse
three it says that Jesus was exalted
right and
sits at the right hand of the Majesty on
high
right yeah I'm familiar with that but
that's not that's not talking about him
having a throne wa so what is he sitting
on what's he sitting on he could be once
again the father is the only one sitting
on that Throne when it say sat down on
the right hand he's not literally
sitting on the right hand of the most
high right what what it says he's
sitting down at the right hand on the
Flor no no no no no when I read Hebrews
1 and3 it says who being the brightness
of his glory thepress image of his
person upholding All Things by the word
of his power when he had purged th sin
sat down on the right hand of the
Majesty of the most high so on the right
hand it's not literally on the right
hand he's next to him right yeah he's
talking about his position so you have
the father so you have the father's
Throne his seat and then you have Christ
next to
him I never once again I never that
Throne is David's Throne oh wait wait
wait so I never argue I never argue I'm
sorry you about to say something about
David yeah does does David does David's
is David's Throne at the right hand of
the father David's Throne is wherever
the Lord says it is and I'm G give the
scripture Revelations three Revelations
3 and 21 to him that overcometh will I
grant to sit with me in my Throne you
just made a wait You made a distinct cap
stop doing this earlier you made a
distinction and said this right here you
what you just quoted is not what you're
talking about so I'm on the same page as
what you mean when you say not what I'm
talking about so you you were saying
that not like this is figuratively when
it talks about giving a certain
Authority or a power or an order right
um you know I'll give you the ability to
sit on my throne and my father's throne
and yada y right so we're not talking
about that we're talking about the
actual Throne of God the Father the
actual Throne of the king Messiah right
that they actually sit on okay I got
okay just so I got 10 minutes um I got a
live stream in 10 minutes good so
David's Throne is in heaven now
okay so when you I just want to answer
so in Revelations did David rule in
heaven or did he rule on
Earth David ruled on Earth okay so how
did his how did his throne get into
heaven to sit right to the next right
hand of the father no problem so y'all
are making I'm just trying to be clear
I'm just trying to make trying to answer
I'm just trying to answer y'all are
saying that Christ is sitting on the
throne I did not I say Christ sits on
David's Throne as I read it and Luke 1
and 32 the father didn't give him his
throne meaning the father's Throne the
father gave him the Throne of his father
David him standing on the right hand of
the Lord or sitting on the right hand of
the Lord is not the throne in
Revelations I just want to read the
Bible what's he what's he sitting
on he's not sitting on the throne okay
you know what PA because Stephen because
when we talk about Vision keep getting
interrupted why y'all let me read the
scripture no dude dude I know Ste
Stephen saw Jesus standing at the right
hand of the father that's not the
scripture I was gonna read he gon you
you you mentioned Stephen that's act
seven go Revelations well I was talking
about Stevens as I was going to
Revelations 3 because y'all making
sitting in Hebrews as if Stephen didn't
see Christ standing so he could be
standing or sitting but he's not
sitting he's not he's not the one
sitting on that Throne who is then it
says that Christ is sitting it says that
Christ sits on high he sat on high next
to no no no once again Hebrew I'm I'm G
just read it Hebrews 1 and3 says I'm
going just read the latter verse the
latter part rather it says he sat down
on the right hand of his majesty on high
the Majesty is on high so where is he
he's on the he's on the right hand of
the one that's on high so he's on high
with him right no he's not that on high
come on
I'm here and I'm right next to whatever
isation no you no when it says sit on
the right hand of the Majesty on high he
could be just the first person in the
hierarchy because he is the first
screaming he's the second person in the
hierarchy but the one that's called on
high is the
Majesty
me like so for example in Revelations in
Revelations damn when did I tell him 10
minutes now I'm mad logic um in
Revelations 3 in Revelations 3 in
Revelations 3:21 when he says to him
that overcometh will I grant to sit with
me in my throne even as I also overcame
and sat down with my father in his
throne that Throne there is not in
literal in this regard we're not sitting
like on top bunch of people just on top
of each other just like Christ is not
thank you but it is letting you know
there's a distinct Throne that Christ
has and there's a distinct Throne that
the father has and the father's throne
is greater wait wait you just said it
there's a distinct Throne that the
father has and there's a throne that the
son has a distinct Throne that the son
has right my question is where is the
son's Throne the son's Throne he when he
rules that's when he has the throne like
he's waiting is he ruling right is he
ruling right now no he's not ruling what
we're we're pushing the truth ofans
chapter one oh my goodness did you just
say Christ is not ruling right now what
I'll explain when I'm saying he's not
ruling is he ruling in this Kingdom no
we have we have I was gonna say
something back we have I'll just say you
already used to that youve been saying
stuff bad keep going I ain't said
nothing bad man you crazy but I was G to
say something right right now the
principality like in Ephesians 6 and9
the Ws of the devil uh wickedness in
high places is ruling right now Christ
is not ruling the planet Earth right now
that's the prophecy the prophecy whether
you what no matter what you think of
Earth and heaven in Revelations 21 when
Jerusalem comes down and then Christ is
ruling that that's what we overcome
that's why Revelations 3 says to him
that overcometh we haven't overcome it
yet we haven't endured to the end we
haven't had Christ open up the excuse me
the most high open up the books and read
everything and then give us the
rulership along with him so no the
kingdom of Jerusalem ain't here so that
Throne is not here that's why it says
he's sitting or standing on the right
hand of the most high doesn't say his
throne is there even if you go to F my
that look where is he sitting is my
question he could be sitting anywhere
he's not sitting on that Throne is he
sitting on high no he's on the
right Psalms it haven't happened
yet if Hebrews 1 and three that you had
us read did not say he was sitting on a
throne it says he was sitting next to
the man on the throne that's what it
said it says he sat down on the right
hand so if the king's chair is here he
could be sitting here he could be
sitting here he could be sitting here
but that chair belongs to the king it
don't belong to nobody else is he at the
same level
platform this
is you got Ephesians one right
hey can this be the last one y'all go to
and then after this I'mma bounce yes no
problem you only because I got I had a
pro impromptu live stream that I
scheduled I actually gota set it up I
know where uh JP can you show my screen
I know you're there did you run
off C about to put you on this live
stream
Logic No I'm not about I wouldn't do
that I I would always be professional
man don't disrespect me like that I'm
just playing with you C man I'm just
playing back man I'm just playing
Ephesians chapter 1 verse 20 to 22 oh my
goodness that uh that he worked in
Christ when he raised him from the dead
and seated him at his right hand where
in the Heavenly places far above all
Rule and authority and power and
dominion and above every name that is
named not only in this
age but also in the one to come and he
has put all and he put all things under
his feet and gave him as head over all
things to the church which is his body
the fullness of him who fills all in all
so Christ Accord according to the
scripture is ruling now in the Heavenly
places above everything he has the
highest position in the Heavenly places
correct yeah the
next so now I'm I'mma say again as I
read Revelations 3 and 21 I was clear
first of all Ephesians 1 and 20 yall
read right yes 20 now right and and 21
let me see if it says the word throne I
don't see the word throne in there oh
yeah he's just sitting on the floor I I
don't see the the I just see sitting at
the right hand when it talks about his
power and might that's what he earned
nobody argues that he earned but in
Revelations 3:21 says to him that
overcometh will I give to sit in my
Throne I'm not arguing he don't have a
throne seat chair whatever you want to
call it that is not my position my
position is that the father's Throne is
not Christ Throne we read that in Luke
1:32 it's clear the throne that Christ
has it's the Throne of his father David
which you already admitted he has two
fathers so if the angel says he's
sitting on the the Throne of his father
David who are you to say that he's not
even in Revelations 5 what does it say
the LI the lion of the tribe of Judah of
the root of David he's from the tribe of
David even in heaven he's from the tribe
of David excuse me I'm saying it wrong
he's from the tribe of Judah he's from
the the root of David even in heaven so
if in heaven he's recognized as the root
of David if the angel says he's sitting
on the throne of David the seat that
he's sitting in is David's seat that he
earned but it's not the most high seat
all right fellas you got my information
log you can hit me up I do gotta hop
onto a live stream I wish I would have
hopped on here a little
earlier you don't text me back so
therefore I'm not gonna you didn't text
me that's C that's cat now I'm bust you
out I'm bust you Facebook you didn't
accept it I sent you a friend request
now any other time you go live you text
me right on my good old iPhone right
here the last time you went live you
text me on the iPhone you did not text
me on Facebook Messenger because the
iPhone is terrible with alerts I think
you know that so if you would have
message me on uh in on the messenger I
would have hopped right on it wouldn't
even been no big deal all right cool
cool all right so I hit you on the
iPhone all right no sweat yeah the last
time you text me was March 14th when you
uh text me about was Judah save and you
wanted me to pull up you didn't want me
to pull up and cut your good brother
logic that's all that was no no no cut
that I'll get up with yall later y'all
be easy man take care man easy all right
man peace right can I say my last
remarks on this oh absolutely go ahead
so um we all we all
heard we all heard what we heard y'all
uh Jesus is sitting on high uh at the
right hand of the Majesty on high oh but
Jesus is not sitting on High um Jesus is
sited at seting at the right hand ruling
above all the powers in the heavenly
plac
above every name above every Dominion
above every Power in the Heavenly places
oh but Christ isn't ruling right now um
or you know you know he's he's gonna be
ruling on David's Throne where is
David's Throne it was on earth right so
what what is Jesus sitting on when he's
in sitting in the Heavenly places above
everything the highest place the the
verses are so clear they're so plain you
have to have bad hermeneutics bad inter
ration of the scripture to reject this
you got to be a black Hebrew Israelite
or possibly a Muslim but this was
tough that's all I got to say oh my God
logic
[Music]